Damas y caballeros, estas son 10 cosas
realmente asombrosas.
Imaginen, si lo desean, que tienen que cargar
todo en sus espaldas.
¿No sería más fácil para mí
si pudiera hacer rodar esto a casa?
Sí, por eso inventaré la rueda.
La rueda, damas y caballeros.
¿Es la rueda algo asombroso? Repitan conmigo.
Sí, ¡la rueda es algo asombroso!
Las grandes pirámides fueron las estructuras
hechas por el hombre más altas del mundo
durante 4000 años.
El faraón tenía esclavos que movían millones de bloques
hasta este sitio para erigir esta bendita lápida.
¿Fueron las grandes pirámides algo asombroso?
Sí, las pirámides fueron algo asombroso.
El Gran Cañón. Vamos.
Tiene casi 80 millones de años.
El Gran Cañón ¿es algo asombroso?
Sí, el Gran Cañón es asombroso.
Louis Daguerre inventó la fotografía en 1829,
y hoy más temprano,
cuando sacaron sus teléfonos inteligentes
y tomaron una foto de sus sándwiches asombrosos,
—Uds. saben quiénes fueron—
(Risas)
¿no fue más fácil que la exposición de la imagen
a placas de cobre recubiertas con plata yodada?
Digo, vamos. ¿La fotografía es algo asombroso?
Sí, lo es.
El Día D, 6 de junio de 1944,
la invasión aliada de Normandía,
la invasión anfibia más grande de la historia mundial.
¿El Día D fue algo asombroso? Sí, fue asombroso.
¿Se alimentaron hoy? ¿Comieron?
Entonces pueden agradecerle a las abejas
porque si no polinizaran los cultivos, no produciríamos alimentos,
y moriríamos todos.
Así de simple.
Una flor no puede levantarse
y tener sexo con otra flor,
eso sí sería asombroso.
(Risas)
Las abejas son asombrosas. ¿Es una broma?
¡El alunizaje! ¡Vamos!
La Apolo 11 ¿es una broma?
66 años después de que los hermanos Wright
despegaran de Kitty Hawk, Carolina del Norte,
Neil Armstrong estaba a 384 000 kilómetros.
Una distancia como de aquí a la luna.
(Risas)
Fue un pequeño paso para el hombre,
¡un gran paso para el asombro!
Tienen toda la razón, lo fue.
Woodstock, 1969: la revista Rolling Stone dijo:
Esto cambió la historia del rock and roll.
En ese entonces las entradas costaban USD 24.
Hoy no compramos ni una camiseta con ese dinero.
La versión de Jimi Hendrix de The Star-Spangled Banner
fue un ícono.
Woodstock ¿fue asombroso? Sí, fue asombroso.
¡Los tiburones! Están en la cima de la cadena alimentaria.
Tienen varias filas de dientes
en sus mandíbulas
y avanzan como una cinta transportadora.
Algunos tiburones pueden perder 30 000 dientes a lo largo de sus vidas.
¿Lo asombroso inspira temor?
Claro que sí, ¡los tiburones son asombrosos!
Internet nació en 1982
y de inmediato se apoderó de la comunicación mundial,
y, esta noche, cuando subamos estas presentaciones
a Internet,
ese tipo siberiano podrá emborracharse
y mirar esta basura;
¡Internet es algo asombroso!
Para terminar, muchos de Uds. no verán la hora
de venir a decirme lo asombrosa que fue esta presentación.
Les ahorraré tiempo.
No fue asombrosa, pero fue verdadera,
y espero que entretenida,
y de todos los públicos que he tenido,
Uds. son el más reciente. Gracias y buenas noches.
(Aplausos)